e outro pessoal e quem fala andar que
exige muito menino está mais um vídeo e
vejam só que concentra em 1984 tem que
parecer algo sem mistério alguma coisa a
ver com o tesouro porque o brinquedo
chama se jorge é que sob o o o que
obrigou a fazer bons jogos aqui no canal
inscreva-se se você já estou habituado a
conviver com os filhos mas muito mais
mesmo que isso ajuda muito o canal e
para mais sobre no presente e outros 16
horas alto do pina por aí anda
o barulho dos padrões nero a roy pirata
jehan 8 em uma carta pessoal tem uma
carga ou o aquecedor do tesouro é
durante milhares e milhares de anos
piratas curadores historiador ladrões
tentaram descobrir um tesouro perdido
mas sem fé é agora sua vez pra galera já
faltou ouro de thrash encontrar o
tesouro só esta é nossa oportunidade de
ficar os milionários bill e fred rutten
fez um vídeo até o fim porque pode ser
que em conta que outro junto aos
caçadores de tesouros encontra uma
pintura de desenho e tapas que tentam
levar aos confins do universo e não
esqueça o x marca o lugar está uma pista
nós temos aqui desde já apresentei de
brinquedo isso eu não sei mas vamos ver
junto sim tenho dois nem três quatro
cinco
meu deus é muito brinquedo 67 a 67 o
número da sorte espero que não haja mais
fraco rasteiro e aí a culpa
calma calma mas qualquer coisa porque
são profissionais na opo agora é um
pirata sério e agora só vão valer os
novos prédios
vamos lá e aqui na embalagem diz será
fácil encontrar o tesouro banhada a ouro
verdadeiro ou seja isto pode ter o mesmo
querendo e aqui atrás mas tem instruções
é esse mesmo encontro o mapa 2 tirar a
cutícula dourada trecho os a moeda pra
tua busca 4 encontra a ferramenta
descansam 15 buscava rocha
meu deus é muita coisa sei se encontram
jorge e uma arma
tomara né mesmo com uma pistola será 7
contra 8 caçador de tesouros 8 enquanto
a arca do tesouro novo junto à água para
dissolver e 10 revela o tesouro eu estou
muito ansioso série a e são 24 figuras
de ação tem aqui dentro muito figura ro
esta é nossa roça eu acho por uma versão
mais fácil retira público dourada e
colocar rocha demais thiago durante 30
segundos é uma instrução milza oo ou já
tenha moeda quícoli muito vencer ou
mesmo uma rocha que é só deixar dentro
d'água 3149 com 30 segundos bastaram
embora a chamada era preciso uma
ferramenta de conversão eu sei que uma
patrulha estranha essa patuá encontrou
mata primeiro encontrou uma vez do mapa
o u1 lapa até e que trazem o tem várias
figuras 64 tem vários tesouros banhada a
ouro olha espanha pirâmide do cauê essa
busca uma barra de ouro uma caverna é um
dragão e um ídolo de ouro usado sua
moeda para a busca pela produção e vem
cá haja sair tem que encontrar estes
três símbolos que no mapa
este não é a este protesto só parece um
saco de dinheiro aqui uma casinha em uma
palmeira então é isso que nós vamos
encontrar puc maria conta que qualquer
coisa tá muito duro aqui é que começa o
pessoal lá encontrei cabeça do
explorador o câncer tesouros vamos lá
tentar encontrar o resto do corpo onde
encontrei que um braço eu tenho passado
por água encontrei que uma perna
acho que encontrei que une estoque o
outro braço época tem dois né ô ô ô
tesouro é o bairro que o baú
o ex padrinho olha só exporta cheio de
espinhos mas eu tenho que outra coisa
bala
vem com plástico não sei porque lúcio
que isto é maciel é que quando encaixar
as peças não sair mas vamos ver agora o
que tem mais aqui dentro que será tanto
muito ansioso por encontrar mais
qualquer coisa o encontrei a não é só
areia dura aula show aqui mas nada e
agora tem que o nosso curador eu vou só
passagens por água e já volto para lá só
tem espécies belas linhas que vão
facultar para montar o nosso procurador
estamos a colocar um braço outro braço
uma perna e está com falta uma pena que
uma perna a opção por que eu vou usar
aquela camisa e mail está muito difícil
é só uma pergunta que encontrei na
internet e é por isso que vocês precisam
explorar muito bem o episódio a
encontrei não se pague enquanto a outra
perna
meu deus toma muito perigosa e outro
para si mesma estrutura do que já tenho
tudo se esclareça mas vamos lá então
abrir o nosso baú esta é a parte mais
importante eu acho que é porque que nós
vamos conseguir achar o nosso torcedor é
nosso 115 maranhão aqui dentro e vamos
ver o que é que indica ok então aqui é
uma instrução um disco e nós não
escavaram que colocaram água é só isso
acho que vou usar a água do forte na
produção e isso olha só a opção for life
manutenção do dólar feche com água
o da bulgária tabu orgulhar porque vou
tentar o tiro não não cama eu sinta
funcionando lucros são barulho
isto unisol a flutuar you eu vou tirar
aqui estão é ouro
classifico enganaram pessoal com certeza
que não vai seguir o homem todos os
tesouros né então nós temos que
continuar a procura tem mais seis
brinquedos onde pode ser ouro e que não
senhor
mas eu acho que o primeiro escuro então
é mas poderia ter sido o nosso voto de
hoje não saiu
o saque do euro pode ser um nome pouco
transparente produção pode ser agora é
puro do caçador de tesouros pessoal nós
conseguimos com uma caveira olha isso
vosso comentário momento em que você
acha que vai reunir até o fim
eu acho que vou encontrar ouro eu acho
que sim embora lá
[Música]
olha pessoal já temos aqui os nossos
seis tesouras completamente molhado e
agora é só acabar e tentar encontrar
nosso melhor a começar já por isso fala
por si um circuito novo risco a mão e me
colocar eu vou juntar as peças todas é
não ok só encontrei todo o esqueleto e
já conta também o baú vamos colocar aqui
do lado eu já tentei dar tudo no filme
um estudo aqui e espero que seja
diferente ou acho que é igual acho que é
igual não acho que é igual à que já
encontramos e que o tesouro estão não
gostou místico egípcio acho que é um
farol mais um conhecedor do tesouro e um
baú em que o jazz eo tudo mulher
esse é o caçador de tesouros gladiador o
capacete é eterna é a partir de maio
mais uma mão mais uma perna e um quer
saber qual é a arma deste conflito é uma
espada uma lança do gladiador
eu sou explorador muito competente eu
sempre ficava sempre escalar aí isso é
muito louco isso é muito louco
olha aí o caçador de tesouros samurai
muito louco e isto é é só temos muita
areia aqui ou ali
agora eu vou fazer com essas não vão ver
porque não vai ser muito chato que no
vídeo eu vou lavar tudo eu vou montar
tudo e possamos fazer se uma composição
bem bonita em cima aqui e vocês vão ver
os toldos montados no fim nós vamos ver
um por um todos os tesouros e ver o que
é que um seio para lá e só temos que
todos os curadores do tesouro e temos já
tudo isto surge que e ajustados abreu
descobrir o que tem dentro embora lá um
por um só que vocês acham que vai ser o
ouro e voltar a colocar aguento disso
surge no fim do dia o que tá entre agora
e este puniu dois punidos
[Música]
a atual infelizmente aconteceu uma coisa
que costuma acontecer muito enquanto eu
abrir todos os nossos bairros como podem
ver toda a merda que ela não estava a
gravar então eu aprendi muita coisa boa
também que muitos tesouros vão
os que já fez tudo fiquei muito feliz e
não estava a gravar portanto vou resumir
pra vocês é que o que aconteceu eu estou
bem chateado porque eu estava muito
vocês vissem o que aconteceu e agora
vocês perderam essa imagem mas eu vou
mostrar eu vou fazer aqui um zoom para
vocês o que seria ok vamos lá a primeira
coisa que sei é que nesta caixa só estou
dizendo a verdade ao cair do ecomuseu
isso mesmo o que sei é que nesta caixa
foi primeiro é juninho é um item comum é
prata muito louca e fiquei bem contente
na próxima do samurai eu ia explodir em
ensinar o pessoal porque vejam só que se
um paralelo é uma moeda tanta guerra o
meu sério fiquei muito contente porque o
samurai é um favoritos em um novo nicho
segundo eu estava muito fácil
visualização instantânea simplesmente
não tá aqui já não cantava nos prontos
em uma moeda de ouro muito bom você o
dragão só nós conseguimos uma moeda de
ouro então quem muito em baixo que
achava que esse êxito e agora o que
significa que sim mas foi a moeda que
estas moedas são me tem como então é
meio podre em pano próximo neste
contexto em que saiu o trompete não me
saiu outra pessoa duro aqui esqueleto
dourado
a caveira dourada esse mesmo tempo e
talvez música saiu outra peça de ouro
são duas equipas que no total caiu
jaguar só serão duas eu fiquei muito
contente e o próximo foi um trompete e
trombone trompete foi lá e fez uma
picada de cobra e não tem um baú cheio
uma sandália de prata olha aí é que
continuam com a sua vez foi ontem sua
mas no geral eu fiquei muito contente
por ser um dos pés de hoje são muito
bonitas sério e tem muito peso tanto eu
não vi que estejam mesmo eu acho que
mas como é que vocês acham que só o
homem é ouro ou não
e é só vou jogar porque construído com
esta exploração do 3g next vocês têm
estado aqueles brinquedo eu inverti por
paciente caso não seja que o tesouro
vocês mudam a peça eo agora ninguém
segura dos diferentes muito o favorito
claro é o samurai pessoal então comenta
embaixo também concorda que o assegure
eu me sinto o samurai que este kit com a
nuvens
longe de bambu e sobe até existe neste
vídeo já sabem sofrer um pequeno canal e
inscrevam se deixem muito moleque e e
sofre quem é aproximar fiquei agora quem
foi nem por isso né
eu não vou limpar eu vou tomar conta do
meu ouro duas linhas coisas preciosas do
programa